[Music]
[Music]
one might have the impression that we
only look for more political background
of Foreign Affairs but actually we need
transport experts we need informations
we need archivists translators of course
[Music]
I really enjoyed working here at the
council firstly you get to meet lots of
people from all the other member states
you get to work on really closely on
issues that affect European citizens as
well and with that learning how the EU
policymaking process works and
especially how our member states de
gauche e8 with one another I'm a trainee
at a Czech translation unit I get to
translate all kinds of documents
sometimes it's just council minutes of
meetings sometimes it's web materials
sometimes it's decisions and inner
documents for the inner use of the
council it's quite varied it feels nice
knowing that somewhere out there there
are documents with my initials on them
now
[Music]
working in the press office of the
council has been a great experience for
me
you practically work as a press officer
and when there is a European Council the
Chinese are asked to help out a pristine
we report on national press conferences
and keep an eye on what is happening on
social media right before during and
after the meeting
[Music]
my name is Anna Crispo I've been working
here the council for the last five years
I started during a traineeship I had the
pleasure to be at the trust office
precisely with the deputy spokesperson
of the cameraman boy the former
President of the European councils and
well since then I've been having
different positions and always connected
to communication and in media what I've
seen happen to quite a few trainees is
that they came here may be relatively
inexperienced or used to working in an
academic setting and then they left
with a much greater sense of what it's
like to you know work in an office
context work also in in a European
context and even in it in a political
context because here at the council we
are so close to European politics this
is where you leaders meet this program
is quite extensive and is a scope is to
give a deeper knowledge of the European
Union as such or European institutions
in this case as such and also to create
a bonding feeling amongst them so they
can go away at the end of their training
ship having you know a network we have a
very high rate of job finding after
after the end of our training
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]